our magic carpet is bound for the
highlands of central turkey
and we will be visiting great cities
like ankara
and konya and a marvelous region
of turkey that is unlike any other part
of the earth
the region known as cappadocia but to
get us there let us obey the words of a
man who spent most of his life
in this extraordinary heartland of the
great nation of turkey
here is an invitation spoken
by a voice from the 13th century
come come whoever you may be
wanderer idolater fire worshiper
come though you may have broken your
vows a thousand times
come come yet again our caravan
is not a caravan of despair
that beautiful invitation was written
in verse by one of the most popular
poets in the world today
a sufi mystic of long ago known as rumi
and we will be visiting his city of
konya
and considering more about his life and
work
as we explore this world that he knew so
well
we are going first to ankara on our
caravan of hope
the capital of modern turkey after the
chaos of the fall of the ottoman empire
and the creation of turkey as a new
state a republic there was a decision
about
which city should be its capital
istanbul
from time out of mind had been the great
city of this part of the world
but it was the decision of ataturk the
founder and
new head of this great young nation that
there should be
a capital more in the heartland of
turkey
the same impulse prevailed for instance
in brazil where brasilia rather than rio
de janeiro on the coast
was chosen for the capital and so it was
that ankara
which had seemed to rather isolated spot
and in
ottoman times had been used as a place
of exile
became the new capital we can get there
from istanbul with a long drive or a
fairly short flight
and we will find that a city of about
four million people a
bustling place uh with a field not
unlike washington dc
filled with administrators and
government officials
it's for the most part a new city it
expanded exponentially as soon as it was
chosen to be the capital
but it is marked with some remarkable
monuments
let's go first to the great mausoleum of
ataturk himself created in the late
1940s and early 1950s
a rather severe place as fits the
founder of a nation of ass plaza an
extraordinary
monument with huge columns around the
central place
and sculpted figures in relief
there's a little museum nearby which i
find very touching
it has among its exhibits not only the
lavish
gifts that were given to ataturk by
heads of state from foreign nations but
ataturk's
own personal possessions all by contrast
with the
gifts extraordinarily and touchingly
simple
it may have seemed rather arbitrary to
choose ankara
as the capital for this new nation but
in fact
there are signs in ankara that it was
somehow marked
out to be a capital city it is in a
region
of ancient capitals within the
ambit of ankara the hills
around it you will find the capital
cities of hittite
kings at places like hattushash and
there among the cyclopean masonry
the huge gates the statues of
warrior kings rows of hittite gods
there the hittite kings ruled an empire
we can fortunately read their writing
because early on in hittite history they
were visited by
assyrians who came to trade but also
brought with them the cuneiform
system of writing so hittite was written
down in cuneiform
and since the symbols could be read it
was possible
using the tablets dug up at these
hittite capitals near
ankara to discover in the 19th century
that the hittite language was an
indo-european tongue a lost ancestral
language
among modern indo-european languages
they had literature they had prayers
they had letters
you can see their homes you can be
reminded of tyrins and myceni back in
greece
they're roughly contemporary and i've
always thought that the work crews once
they'd finished tattoos must have gotten
on board ship
and gone over to get new jobs building
the cyclopean masonry of those palaces
in greece
you will find the remains the
artifacts dug up at tattoos and the
other
other hittite sites in a fantastic
museum
in ankara it is a museum of anatolian
civilizations
and in this museum are not the greek and
roman antiquities that are so abundant
in the cities along the coast but rather
the remains of the extraordinary
cultures that blossomed in the heartland
of anatolia now that word anatolia
means the place where the sun comes up
it is a
designation for this land mass which is
also sometimes called asia minor
little asia given by people to the west
the greeks
looking east at the rising sun and
seeing it come up over the
coasts and mountains of turkey the
anatolian cultures go back
thousands of years and you will see
among the treasures
of this museum of anatolian
civilizations
in ankara you will see the remains from
an extraordinary site
further south in central turkey a place
called
chateau huyuk
chat goes all the way back to about 9000
bc
it was first excavated by an english
archaeologist named
melart who noticed the twin mounds
or tells and that's what chateau huyuk
means
a forked mound a forked hill
in this turkish countryside
dug into those mounds sure that he would
find something but never dreaming that
he was going to be
finding one of the most early examples
of a complex human society
who had created for themselves a sort of
hive
of clay buildings in which to live chat
huyuk reminds me of the great pueblo
cities of the american southwest
not a city with a grid of streets with
public monuments and so
on but rather house and rooms set
wall to wall in a vast complex
people reaching the outside world not
through doors onto a street
but climbing up ladders to holes in the
roof that opened onto their terraced
rooftops
among the extraordinary things that mel
art found at chateau huyuk
was that these people had already
developed an extremely complex religion
and an extremely complex artistic
tradition to
express it mellard found an
extraordinary figurine
of a mother goddess as he believed her
to be
a powerful looking woman with great
sagging breasts a protuberant
belly perhaps she's actually pregnant
she may be giving birth
seated on a throne and the the arms of
her throne are
leopards here is a powerful emblem of
the mistress of beasts
she was found in a green bin but
nonetheless
when he coupled this figure with the
evidence of frescoes
and other art he realized that there was
a huge cult
of worship for what we can only consider
gods
as well as an elaborate cult of the dead
skeletons were found under the floors
not in separate
graveyards but in with the living human
heads had been taken and
treated separately as if honored
ancestors
could still be present joining with the
festivities with the daily life
of their descendants
itself lies 28 miles outside our second
great city
cogna and this is a city that is the
uh happy home of the great poet rumi
he was a man born in tajikistan
grew up speaking persian traveled
westward with his family into the area
known as room by persians because it was
the old roman
empire and so ironically his nickname
this great persian mystic just means the
man from rome or the man of roman
territory
he was trained to be a jurist an expert
on islamic
law he was brought up in the sufi
tradition and he had a life-changing
experience
when he met a mystic named shams
and became his disciple and friend this
changed his life he too became a mystic
he began to seek meaning in life that
lay outside
holy texts and scripture that lay in
personal inspiration
and he had a poetic gift like few others
that have ever been given to mortals in
this world
so strong that even today books of his
poems
sell millions of copies even in the and
i mean no disrespect to the english
translators even in the weak medium
of a translation he wrote a poem
about that lost friendship
because one day one evening i guess it
was there was a knock at the door charms
went out
this this beloved master and never came
back
it's still not known what happened to
him and for quite a while after that
rumi spent his existence spent his days
searching
for his lost master as far away as the
city of damascus and syria
and yet finally he came to his senses
and he recorded his thoughts in a poem
a poem that applies to many of us who go
through life seeking for what we
look for in another person why should i
keep looking
he and i are one his spirit speaks
through me
i have only been seeking myself
now the museum in konya for rumi is in
fact his mausoleum
much like the mausoleum that we saw of
ataturk in ankara
but it's filled with memorials of his
life and his teaching
it also has a beautiful display of the
musical instruments
the little flutes and pipes and three
string violins
that were used in the ecstatic dances
that evolved into the tradition of the
whirling
dervish and this great tradition of the
dance in which the spinning
ultimately puts the dancer into an
altered state a religious ecstasy
goes straight back to rumi himself
the museum at konya is also rumi's
mausoleum
and there are words he said about dying
and
graves that we should remember when we
are there
when we die he said do not look for our
tomb in the earth
seek it instead in human hearts
that mausoleum its sight was originally
a rose garden
owned by a wealthy man of central turkey
when rumi died he
allowed the mausoleum for him there as
he had allowed it for rumi's father
and thus there came to be this center of
reverence
but also a center of study and a center
where the tradition of the whirling
dervishes growing out of the sufi
side of islam is still kept strong and
once a year there is a great gathering
of dervishes from all over turkey in
this spot
it's in winter if you're not there on
that
excellent time you will find the
whirling dervishes occasionally
around the country it is always worth
seeing their amazing performances
even if one is outside the circle of
understanding
exactly what is going on for the people
doing those amazing dances
many people are drawn to central turkey
not for the cities
and not for the history of islam and
its literature and its dances but rather
for
one of the truly extraordinary
geological landscapes to be found
anywhere
this is in a region called cappadocia or
cappadocia as i said if you anglicize it
and every ci
or ti is pronounced sh cappadocia
meant to the persians in the east and
the romans in the west
land of horses i grew up near the
bluegrass region of kentucky where the
limestones
are a source of calcium for the grass
that grows above them
and the horses grow strong bones from
cropping that grass
exactly the same thing happened in
cappadocia
where horses simply by eating the local
grass got
very strong bones with an extra dose of
calcium because of the minerals in the
rocks below
but these were not limestones
millions of years ago three big
volcanoes which you can still see
in cappadocia today with their snowy
summits
they went berserk they spewed
ash they spewed lava over this landscape
the original limestones which were here
were covered over by up to 100 yards 100
meters 300 feet
of ash which gradually compacted down to
a volcanic stone called
tough looks very solid but it's actually
quite easy to work as you might expect
of compacted ash
but then they began to erupt flows of a
heavy volcanic rock
called basalt which spread out over the
surface of this
soft compacted ash the result was a
situation that looked quite stable
initially
but when the rains came and began to
carve gullies in the basalt
and when that that water from the summer
rains froze in the hard snowy winters of
the central highlands
all the water that had gone down into
cracks in the basalt
froze and expanded breaking up that cap
even further and at last little by
little
the underlying tough was exposed to
daylight again
in these deep gullies the water would
now rush around
and shape cones pillars
standing masses of the tuff but still
leaving part of the basalt cap on top
the results were the famous fairy
chimneys
of cappadocia i did not come up with the
name
but it is a name that tries to express
the magical quality
of this landscape where these golden
yellow columns and spires and cones
rise up from the plane or fill
valleys and often poised
on the top of one of these columns
like a an object on a pedestal will be a
block
of that darker harder stone the basalt
that flowed from the volcanoes at the
end of this cataclysm
that created cappadocia the result is a
landscape that attracts geologists from
all over the world
but ordinary people too because it is of
a dreamlike
extraterrestrial sort of nature it's as
if you were in
a version of monument valley from our
own american southwest
that had somehow been taken into an
utter dream state
of unreality
people were drawn to cappadocia because
of the high quality of the grazing
ground
i mentioned the horses already but
farming of all kinds took place on this
plain and in these valleys the soil
turned out to be very good for
grapes and there's in fact an industry
of wine today in cappadocia you're
able to try it yourself cereal crops
were grown
out on the plains people flourished
it became an important province of the
roman empire claimed by tiberius
it developed a strong culture and lots
of population centers during the
early christian period but it was also
one of those
crossroads of cultures in two senses
many different cultural influences met
here but many
conquerors also coveted this rich and
extraordinary part of the world
or made it a thoroughfare as they moved
from east to west
with their hordes with their cavalry
with their
armies people of cappadocia found
themselves
in a very dangerous position
it may have been as early as the 7th or
8th century bc
that a tradition began in cappadocia of
dwelling as troglodytes that is a word
that means
cave dwellers the tough
tuff that compacted volcanic ash was so
easy to dig
it could almost be excavated with a
sharpened stick
much easier to create a home by
burrowing into
the side of a cliff than building a home
of stone out in the open
two kinds of troglodytes emerged and
developed in
this cappadocian region let's look first
at those who
are most easily matched to troglodytes
elsewhere in the world
at places for instance such as the great
valley of
petra in jordan people who find a sheer
face of a cliff
and burrow back into it creating a home
creating a holy place
creating a sort of human-made cave
if you want to see these communities in
their perfection
you must go to two sites gureme
and zelba that have been declared
part of the world heritage by unesco
they are also official open-air museums
preserved by the turkish government
forever to show the world this unique
culture that evolved in these distant
valleys of cappadocia
gureme and zelva show us a late period
in these troglodytic operations
they show us the christian period when
monks nuns groups of people who simply
wanted to have their
homes in the valley but their places of
worship up in the rocks
would send their artisans up into these
valleys halls
dwelling places chapels would be
hollowed out of the rock
and then elaborately painted with
[Music]
frescoes
[Music]
whole communities grew up here slightly
hidden communities of monasteries and
nunneries
christian communities it may have begun
very early on when it was still illegal
to be christian
before the emperor constantine
proclaimed
that christianity was indeed a religion
that could be accepted by the roman
empire
some of them may have their roots way
back in a pre-christian period where the
people
are taking advantage of these lonely
spots
simply to get away from those main
highways of history that are bringing so
many hordes through their homeland
whatever the case there is a tranquility
a beauty a spiritualism about these
holy places at gureme and zelda
where you feel a union of natural wonder
and spiritual fervor that has very few
equals anywhere in this world
[Music]
but even more remarkable is a recent
discovery
there were other troglodytes in
cappadocia
who instead of going up on the cliffs
went underground it had long been known
that on some
farm yards there would be a stable or a
storage
place below ground level and it was also
known that there were certain
wells out in the countryside of
cappadocia
where after letting a bucket down
hundreds of feet
on a rope you would bring up fresh water
in the 20th century people began to
explore these excavations underground
and what they found astonished not just
the world of historians and
archaeologists
but the world at large there were hidden
cities under the landscape of cappadocia
almost 40 of these hidden cities have
been discovered
only a few have been opened up excavated
explored
it's not known exactly when they began
it is clear from the material
in them that they were used by
christians
hidden christian communities to what
extent they were using the
passageways staircases underground halls
that have been carved out by earlier
groups earlier cultures and
civilizations in cappadocia
we don't know but we do know that there
is nothing
else in the world that equals the
complexity and the scale
of these sunken cities
these cities in cappadocia and the two
most famous
are derenkuyou and
kai makla typically there were round
doors those doors are like the doors of
fortresses
they are huge round millstones
that are set in grooves so that people
inside
having entered that circular opening are
able to
release the little stone that is holding
that millstone up
and let it roll down into place and no
battering ram in the world is going to
be able to knock that in
and allow access to an enemy outside
on the surface those doorways are the
evidence we use to say
these are cities of refuge these are
hidden cities for people who are living
in fear of something and somebody
and need more than a dry warm place to
pass the winter
how many people are involved here it's
staggering
but archaeologists and historians who
have worked here
estimate that tens of thousands of
people
may have lived in individual sites
among these 40 or so underground cities
the cities were built in levels
up to eight levels have been found and
there may be many more below them
each underground city was a warren of
rooms
dug into the tuff so every wall is stone
and comprising ventilator shafts
which reach the surface and allow the
fresh air continually to come
in on the surface those shafts are in
some cases very difficult to find so
it's not likely that an enemy passing
through
would be able to locate them or block
them up
and you would also find staircases and
corridors
leading through the city connecting all
the rooms together
there were stables underground for the
livestock
there were presses where grapes could be
pressed to make the wine
there were vast storage areas where
water food meat cheese could be kept
through a long
period of time there were individual
rooms for
people or entire families to live in
there were
meeting halls great size
underground churches
work rooms and then places where
having burrowed straight down to the
water table
the precious water could be drawn up in
buckets as from a well
and you may remember back to that shaft
which went so far down that was one of
the clues that there might be something
underground
in one of the spots where one of these
cities was discovered
i recently saw a television program that
argued that derinkuyu
in specific was so extraordinary that
nothing
in this world could explain it it must
be the sign of extraterrestrials
i don't sympathize with that argument i
do sympathize with anybody who finds it
difficult to wrap their minds around
the idea of a community the size of a
fair-sized
town getting together to resolve on the
concerted effort
necessary to burrow into that tough
soft though it may be and hollow out
these miles of corridors
we are standing just at the beginning of
the study of these underground cities
it's a problem that they're
archaeologically very hard to date
because although you may be able to date
the artifacts that are found in them
the actual digging is not dateable and
how many centuries way back into the
past
this strange troglodytic life may go we
still
can't truly estimate nonetheless they
are
marvelous testimony to the power of
human communal effort and shared vision
they are marvelous testimony to the
imagination and fortitude
of these people living long ago on this
high anatolian plateau
but at the same time they are testimony
to the toughness of existence
some centuries ago in this world which
today
seems like such a place for meditation
for the beauties of nature for living a
very good life
if you go to cappadocia today you can
visit these
sites like gourmet and zelda
and then go stay in a hotel which fronts
on a cliff
and in which your room may indeed be set
back
into that cliff in the same way that
those troglodytes of the christian
period who dug
their chambers into the sides of cliffs
would have recognized very well and
those make very snug places to pass the
night
no one has yet created an underground
hotel i'm not sure i would want to stay
in one
but those cities are in many cases also
open to visit
they're lit for certain areas along the
passages
none of them are open throughout their
extent i recommend
trying to find a time when they are not
too crowded because
the passages are narrow and
claustrophobia can easily start to take
over
and even though those passages are now
illuminated
with artificial light it can become very
quickly oppressive
underground just as it can be in a small
cave
the feeling of the earth closing in upon
you but it's worth doing just to try to
put
ourselves back in the place of those
whom fear had driven underground
but whose ingenuity had created such a
remarkable solution
to their predicament
no visit to cappadocia is complete
without a balloon ride
and i urge you to take one to have the
full
spiritual experience of taking in this
extraordinary landscape just as eagles
would do when they fly over it
the balloons mainly take off at 5 00 a.m
this is not a windy part of the world
for the most part but at 5 00 a.m
the wind is at its minimum and there in
the early dawn light you will see the
balloons
popping up from various sites over the
cappadocian
landscape taking a few lucky folk up
into the air
the balloon captains are experts they
will work their way up into little
valleys
rise up sheer cliffs you can get a close
look
into those little dwellings and above
all take in not the human side of
cappadocia
but the natural side those spires and
columns
gleaming and the oblique rays of the
morning sun
those dark caps of basalt poised
seemingly miraculously
on the top of tiny pedestals landscapes
that look as if they come from another
world
all this can be yours for about an hour
of magic and here again
i feel that roomie can provide us with
the words to enjoy this
incredible panorama we'll end with one
of his poems
i perished as a rock and became a plant
i perished as plant and rose to animal
i perished as animal and i was made
human
why should i fear when was i diminished
by dying
yet once more shall i die as a man
to soar with angels
the great courses is a unique publisher
for more than 20 years we produced
college-level courses
taught by only the most engaging
professors that universities like
harvard
stanford princeton vanderbilt and
georgetown have to offer
we've created a university of the best
everyone has the capacity to carry on
learning designed in careful
collaboration with our customers
our courses are hand crafted from
beginning to end
for the needs of lifelong learners like
you
most publishers don't guarantee their
work
we do every great course comes with our
lifetime
satisfaction guarantee if a course is
anything short of completely satisfying
you can return it
for another course or for a full refund
no questions asked the only thing left
is your decision just say no to the dead
time of car radio chatter or junk
television
and embark on exciting intellectual
adventures with the great courses
great learning experiences that will
stay with you for the rest of your life
visit us online at thegreatcourses.com
to browse through our extensive catalog
of over 350
comprehensive courses in subjects such
as history
science literature better living
philosophy fine arts and more
or give us a call at 1-800-832-2412
and speak to our knowledgeable customer
care team
the great courses the leader in lifelong
[Music]
learning
you